One specific example for the men's side
platform is the Google Display Network.
The Google Display Network GDN is
a collection of over a million websites,
apps, videos, and
blogs that show AdWords ads.
Basically these million plus sites are
using Google to help them offer their
page to monetize by
providing advertisers with
online real estate to advertise on.
The Google algorithm will target
the ads to the appropriate audience
by ensuring that the ads
are relevant for the page content.
Will do this matching based on the
keywords you select and other factors.
This will give you a much wider audience
than just being in search results.
>> With GDN,
you have the opportunity to fine tune
where you want your ads to be seen.
Beyond selecting audience
based on key words,
you can choose topics to
narrow your audience.
So for Abarkment we can choose to
focus on dog related websites or
pick a specific site like
one that sells pet supplies.
Or we can block our ads from certain
sites that aren't relevant to what we
do, like a site that's dedicated
to hating dogs and loving cats.
We can even focus on people who
have been to our site before and
re target them when
they go to other sites.
This is called remarketing and
you can find out more about
that in the instructor notes.
>> It's called a display network.
Because unlike Google search,
where you can use only text ads.
Here you can display all types
of formats like text, image,
interactive, and video ads.
To learn more about this check
out the instructor notes.
>> So with AdWords beyond Google search,
we can target the display network.
And specifically for
mobile, you can capture the mobile
Google display network.
So if you have a mobile website,
you can advertise and
with mobile text ads,
or mobile image ads,
that capture users that are browsing
different sites on their mobile phone.
And they may see one of your ads and
decide to click on it and
go to your mobile site.
So that's our regular mobile GDN,
Google Display Network,
that's more to drive users
to your mobile site.
The other opportunity you have
is to drive app installs,
and we recommend setting up a campaign
where you would target apps.
So your ad would actually
show in other apps.
So when a user is, for
example, using an app of maybe
you want to specify a certain category
in which you want to target users.
So for example let's say,
I like to travel a lot.
As a user, I might be on a lot
of different travel apps.
Hotel apps, flight apps,
whatever it may be.
But it's maybe I also
have a dog at home and
I need to make sure that I have
housing for my dog while I'm gone.
Well then as a dog Airbnb business
you can target users
who are in travel apps.
So that would be a type of
targeting you could set up.
Find users who are you know
most likely to travel.
And they're already
probably using travel apps.
And then I want to target my
ad to show when they're using
one of those travel apps.
So you can think about what's the best
type of targeting to capture that target
audience for you.
So one thing that I'm really
excited about is AdWords just
released a new type of,
a new campaign type for
display targeting specifically for
app promotion.
So, it's called
the Universal App Campaign, and
it's one of the easiest
campaigns you can set up.
Which is why [LAUGH] I really like it.
All you need to do is link your app to
the campaign and say I want to drive
users to install my app and this is
my target and cost for install price.
And then you really just type
up four different lines that
could be cycled through for the ad
created and then AdWords does the rest.
They create the Add formats, and
then they then add words will
determine all of the targeting.
The great thing about our
universal app campaign
is that it targets all the different
platforms that Google can offer.
So that would include Google search and
Google Play,
but also the Google Display Network.
We were talking about it with
target all categories for apps.
So you can have in app ads.
And then, it also targets YouTube.
Now, we haven't talked
about YouTube yet, but
let's say that you have a YouTube
video promoting your business.
So you can drop that video
in this campaign, and
it will also start
targeting users on YouTube.
So the great thing is,
it covers all the different bases,
it's a really easy set up.
And it just drives downloads at
your target cost per install.
So, it's a campaign that is easy to
set up and it knows what you want.
Ideally, it's going to deliver that
within a couple weeks of testing.